well i just read that uh judge judy made
147
million dollars left 147 million dollars
in a year
just just one year 140 for hosting a
show
where every episode involves her yelling
at a guy who's getting sued because
he stole his neighbor's garden hose or
something i've never actually seen the
show i just assumed that's what it is
but um i i mean i just don't understand
how do you make that kind of money
hosting a show that airs at 1 30 p.m on
a tuesday that's i just i don't
understand
but let me just say she makes 147
million dollars in a year
yet she has never given me even a
million dollars she could give me a
million dollars
and and it would be like no she wouldn't
even notice it and i have
she has never once given me a million
dollars which i just find to be really
rude
you ever think about that with like
really rich people think about bill
gates
has so much money that he could easily
give me 100 million
he could give me a hundred million
dollars and he would never even notice
that it was gone
yet bill gates has never once given me
100 million dollars
if you can believe it i know it just it
seems i mean it's
it's extremely rude um and this is why
we need socialism all right um i want to
talk about something
i i this well i don't want to talk about
it it's it's
incredibly horrible but um
and in fact when i first saw this story
i was i was
my plan was to not talk about it because
it's so horrible makes me so angry that
i don't even know if i can i don't know
what kind of analysis i can really offer
because it just it that's how angry it
makes me but
maybe you saw this headline um on the
daily wire yesterday
mom says six-year-old son is transgender
dad disagrees
now he might lose his son
so the story goes a texas father is
fighting for his son in court
after pushing back on his ex-wife's
claim that their six-year-old is a
transgender girl
according to court documents the young
boy only dresses as a girl
when he's with his mother who has
enrolled him in first grade as a female
named luna
the father however conden contends that
his son consistently chooses to wear
boys clothes
violently refuses to wear girl's clothes
at my home
quote unquote and identifies as a boy
when he's with him
the federalist reports that the mother
has accused the father
of child abuse the mother is accusing
the father
of child abuse in their divorce
proceedings
for not affirming james as transgender
and is looking to strip the data of his
parental rights
she is also seeking to require him to
pay for the child's visit to a
transgender affirming therapist
and transgender medical alterations
which may include hormonal sterilization
starting at age eight the father has
been legally barred from speaking to his
child about sexuality and gender from a
scientific or religious perspective
and from dressing his son in boy's
clothes he is legally
barred from dressing his son in boy's
clothes he has to offer girls and boys
outfits for the child to wear
the boy consistently refuses to wear
dresses according to the father
the boy was diagnosed with gender
dysphoria
by a gender transition therapist
a gender transition therapist decided
that the boy has gender dysphoria
you wonder has this gender transition
therapist ever
met a child who uh they would not
diagnose as gender dysphoric
um and by the way the mother is a
pediatrician
according to the therapist's notes the
boy chose to identify as a girl when he
was in sessions alone with his mother
alternatively he chooses to identify as
a boy
when he is in sessions alone with his
father
the federalist reports a dossier filed
with the
with the dallas court says that under
the skilled eyes of a therapist the
child was presented two pieces of paper
one with the word james
one with the word luna and asked to pick
the name he preferred
when the appointment only included his
mother james selected luna
um the name and gender he uses as
mother's home and in his first grade
classroom
when the appointment was only with his
father however james pointed to the boy
named james
not the girl name um moreover the father
has collected testimony from
friends and other people saying that the
boy
is just a normal boy who likes being a
boy
uh and it goes on from there
i mean this poor kid um
imagine how confused and scared this
poor boy is
uh i mean does he even understand
what's going on of course he doesn't
he's being asked
to choose between two alter egos he's
being
given a choice between wearing dresses i
i mean
this kid has no clue what's going on
he's six years old
he just wants to be a kid
yet he's got his mother who is an evil
evil woman let's be clear about that
this mother is an
evil person um and anyone who defends
the mother
or agrees with the mother is also an
evil
person so this is not i know we're
supposed to be all
into bipartisanship and you know we
don't judge people for their beliefs and
all beliefs are valid and kumbaya let's
come together
no no no no no um if you hear stories
like this and you think oh yeah well
that's right that's
you know the mother's doing the right
thing then you're just a bad person
you're a demented evil person and i want
nothing to do with you
honestly i don't respect your beliefs i
don't respect your opinions
you're completely wrong and i have no
respect for you i just don't
th this is so i told you that how angry
this makes me like
how can it not make you angry they're
gonna chemically castrate this boy
at the age of eight they're gonna start
castrating him
how can anyone read that and not be
filled
with anger for the sake of this child
he is being physically psychologically
emotionally abused mangled
tortured destroyed all to fulfill the
perverse
insane desires of the mother this is
this is easily one of the worst cases of
child abuse i have
ever read about in my life
think of they are going to destroy this
kid they are
his life and his body they're ruining
everything
about him um in a
in a sane or a just society this mother
would be in prison
forever lifetime sentence that's what
she deserves
i i i draw no distinction between this
mother and
any of the other any of the of the other
uh horrible child abusers
that you might read about this is
horrendously
unimaginably evil
now um there are three
other thoughts that come to mind after
after reading this
uh well more than more than that but i
have to control myself i can't say
everything i can't i can't tell you
everything i really think about this
woman this mother uh this horrible
disgusting
monstrous woman because if i do well i
just i can't i can't say it all
so i'm gonna move past that but here's
what comes to mind first of all
what we're seeing here in real time this
is what makes it just so
terrifying it's just so demented and
disturbing is we're seeing in real time
how mental illness is being instilled
implanted into the mind of a child he
he is the mother is trying to force the
child to be mentally ill
um and and he's resisting
he doesn't want it but how long can a
child resist he is he has no idea what's
going on
how long can a six-year-old withstand
this
he's trying to resist but at what point
does this does does the child say
fine i'm just gonna wear the dress i
guess mommy really thinks i need to wear
dresses
so i guess i should just wear the dress
mommy really thinks that i'm a girl so i
guess i'm a girl
mommy really wants me to take this drug
that's going to um
you know make me not a boy anymore so i
guess i just need to do it
i mean it sounds like the boy is is
still at the point of resisting but at a
certain point you know no child can
resist forever
um at a certain point he's going to be
when he's being
manipulated and exploited like this
eventually
it's going to sink in it would for any
kid
um what we have here this this is ba i
don't know if you've
munchausen syndrome by proxy i don't
know if you've ever heard of manchester
by by proxy
syndrome that's when a parent usually a
mother
causes her own child to be sick and uh
and either she can fabricate symptoms in
some cases
or she can actually make the child sick
poison the kid
uh you know not give him
enough food so that he's malnourished uh
whatever the case may be very often in
these cases the child is
is made sick by the mother and
the mother does this because well
she does this number one because she's
just a sick person herself but
her motivations you know she wants
attention she wants to be seen as the
white knight who's caring for a sick
child so she makes her child sick
or she just wants her child to need her
and to be completely dependent on her so
she makes the kids sick for that reason
and that's basically what seems to be
happening here this is a mental illness
a maybe not a physical illness yet
although there are physical
ramifications
but this is a mental illness that is
being caused in the child
by the mother this is a perfectly normal
healthy young boy a boy who just wants
to be a boy wants to be a kid wants to
enjoy his life have fun
but the mother and the medical
establishment remember this woman is a
pediatrician
and then there's a thera a therapist
involved as well so the mother and the
medical establishment
they have plucked this kid out of his
life and they have said
no no you have to be horribly confused
about who you are
we want you to have an identity crisis
so we will create one
no sorry little boy you're not allowed
to have a normal life
we're going to ruin your life um because
because it would make
because that's the trendy thing
you know i am the mother and and it's
it's trendy to have a
to have a transgender kid so i'm gonna
make you be one
you know what a child needs a child
needs clarity
instruction guidance and then he also
needs
at a certain point for adults to just
get out of the way and let him be a kid
so in other words a kid needs to be a
kid
within the safe and clarifying structure
of a loving
and attentive um and caring
family and this child does not have any
of that thanks to the mother
he has the opposite of that he is
getting the opposite
of what he needs
now fast forward 15 years
um imagine that the kid is 21 years old
and if we had never heard this story
before if there was no father there to
fight for him
valiantly as this father is doing and by
the way imagine
you know we're talking about how bad it
is for the kid and obviously the child
is the
is the number one victim in this
situation but um
imagine being the father
you know imagine imagine this this this
happening to your son your son being
destroyed this way
by these perverts and these maniacs
and you're being legally prevented by
the courts from stepping in and doing
anything about it
can you imagine can you imagine the
courts telling you as a father
that you know you're not allowed to get
your
your son dressed in normal boy clothes
you have to provide dresses for them
this is so insane what's go
could anyone 15 years ago could anyone
have imagined that this is where we
would be
even just 15 years ago this is how far
we've fallen and just in just in just
a decade decade and a half nobody could
have conceived of this 15 years ago
and here we are um
so just imagine fast forward another 15
years
kids 21 years old if we had never heard
of this story if there was no father
there to fight for him
if the mother were to succeed in having
the child chemically castrated
literally physically forcing him to be a
female to take on this female identity
then it's uh it's 15 years later and he
identifies as a woman
quote unquote now the left
would would take him and they would use
him as another example and they would
say
look see some biological males just
naturally
identify as women but there's nothing
natural about this we we are seeing
we're seeing how this process really
plays out in real time um
and we are seeing how he is being shaped
this way
he is molded this delusion
is forced into his skull
he's not being given a choice really
and he didn't stand a chance
so what we call when we see this this
transgenders and we say oh you know it's
just naturally arising
none of this is natural either this is a
mental illness that just
came up on its own somehow as mental
illnesses sometimes do
or i think probably more often than that
more commonly you've got some form of
abuse that happens to a child at a young
age
and uh and that's how they end up as
transgender later in life
now it may not always be this kind of
abuse where you've got a parent
forcing transgenderism on the child but
this kind of thing does happen i think
it happens much more frequently now it
certainly happens more frequently now
than it did than it did in years past
but you could also have other forms of
abuse that cause the child to be
confused
about who he is ashamed of who he is
naturally
and then and then to go and seek other
identities
so uh there's just this is this is not a
natural process that takes place
second point i think we should also be
clear about something else this child
is being sexually abused
and i think we should that's what we
should call it
we we should call this sexual abuse
because that's what it is
this is not just physical abuse
emotional abuse
this is sexual abuse uh this is sexual
abuse in a very literal way because
his sexuality is being abused
his sexuality is being perverted mutated
destroyed his sexuality his natural
sexuality is being taken
from him so in the most
in the most literal and direct kind of
way
i think we could call this sexual abuse
and that is what we should call it
because it deserves the same kind of
visceral
anger and disgust that um that anyone
feels and experiences
when they hear about child sexual abuse
this deserves to be put
in that category and thought of in the
same way
and again if we were a sane and just
society it would deserve to be punished
the same way
third point you know i have often
said i've made the point many times that
the transgender agenda conflicts with
contradicts feminism um
and i think that's that's still true but
in cases like this
you see how actually the two go go
go together they go hand in hand so you
see how in some cases militant feminism
and transgenderism
form a kind of dangerous and unholy
alliance
so it would seem that in this case this
woman hates
boys so much that she wants to turn her
son into a girl
and i think this is and this is this is
something that even i have missed when
i've been talking about this and i
well you know i say all the time why
aren't feminists resisting this more
and um i think this is one of the
reasons
that i've overlooked this is why
so many feminists go along with the
transgender thing because it's anti-male
it's anti-boy
why do you think such a large percentage
of transgenders are boys
that seems like a weird coincidence
doesn't it why is that
if this is just a naturally arising
thing gender is fluid blah blah blah
then why is it that most of these then
why is it happening to boys most of the
time
um why the vast majority of them boys
because this is a this is a we live in
an anti-boy
anti-male culture we live in a culture
dominated by feminism
and so that's what this is
what the mother is really saying is i
want a girl i don't want a boy
um and so i'm gonna turn my son
into a girl and i think that's what our
culture does in a
you know on a on a in a general sense
that's what our culture is doing
our culture is saying well girls are
better than boys we would rather have
girls than boys
so we're going to take these boys and
we're going to turn them into girls
by whatever means necessary up to
and including chemical castration
i mean one of these days 100 years from
now 200 years
from now uh 500 years from now
like archaeologists are going to go back
future archaeologists
centuries in the future they're going to
go back and they're going to you know
dig up the the remains of our doomed
civilization
and they're gonna find evidence of of
these sorts of things and they're just
gonna
scratch their head do you realize we are
living through things
right now that archaeologists in the
future are
are going to are going to spend
are going to spend their entire careers
debating and trying to figure out try to
get to the bottom of
trying to figure out how this could have
happened
we are experiencing we are experiencing
right now
what will be in the future a mystery
where people are going to debate how did
the how did this ever happen that they
how is it that this that this ancient
civilization ever became confused
about what a man is and what a what a
woman is
look at this strange weird custom that
they would have where they would
forcibly turn boys into girls
why did they do this were they
worshiping some sort of deity and it's
going to be a it's going to be they're
going to be writing thesis papers and
they're going to be you know publishing
papers and scientific journals
debating this question
and the thing is we're living through it
right now and it's kind of a mystery
even to us
we don't even exactly know where this
came from or why it's happening
when and why and where did we cross this
kind of rubicon
where all of a sudden we became confused
about these basic facts of life these
basic biological facts
it's really a horrible thing um so let's
let's pray for this young man
and for this uh for this father who is
who is
fighting heroically um to save his son
and uh and let's let's let's hope that
and pray that he succeeds
all right um i think that's oh actually
one one other thing i wanted to mention
before we wrap up here
um not nearly as important as
the subject i was just discussing but
i wanted to tell you i wanted to tell
you what happened to me this morning um
and this has just happened to me way too
many times in my life
and i'm tired of it and so it needs to
be addressed
um here here's what happened i i pulled
up to a four-way stop
okay just happened this morning
and i got to the stop probably uh
probably a
half a second before another car pulled
up
but the other car that pulled up they
were on my right
so if if we had arrived simultaneously
at the four-way stop
they would have had the right-of-way but
we were not simultaneously
simultaneous yet our arrivals were so
close together that i thought he might
not realize that i have the right of way
so
i very generously very magnanimously in
an act of
unimaginable kindness
in order to avoid any confusion i
yielded the right of way to him
and i and i gave him the wave i said you
know i did this go ahead
and i even nodded my head go ahead
that's what i did
and i waved him on but this anarchist
refused to go right because then what
did he do and you've seen people
then he waved me on and said he said no
go ahead so i'm waving him he's waving
to me
he's refusing my act of kindness so i
i say okay so i switched my wave to this
and i say okay
i switched my wave to a thank you and i
said okay fine i'll go
and then i started to go but then in a
delayed reaction as i'm starting to go
he decides at that moment to take me up
on the offer that i've now rescinded
and then he starts to go so then i stop
and i wave him on and then he's delayed
in every in every case
he stops and waves me on and now we're
just stopping and going and waving we're
looking at
we look like we're having seizures in
the car so finally i took on
took charge of the situation and i just
plowed right through
but it was a very traumatic and
potentially dangerous moment and uh it
happens way too often at four-way stops
and just
in just in general in life so here's
what we're gonna do when i am dictator
of the world
there's going to be a new law and it
will apply
not only to four-way stops but to all
similar social situations
and the law goes like this when somebody
extends
a minor act of courtesy towards you in
order to facilitate a social interaction
you must accept that courtesy
you must say thank you and just accept
it you
may not decline the courtesy and deflect
it back
to the person who offered it to you this
isn't dodgeball this is not courtesy
dodgeball where you're dodging it
throwing it back to me we're not doing
that so you take the kindness
you say thank you you move on with your
with your life another example this
would be like if you're going through a
door
and you hold the door for someone but
then they come in behind you and they
hold it behind you and they say no after
you
or even worse when it's a double door
situation and you hold the left door for
someone as they're coming in but then
they go through the right door even
though you're holding the left
door just leaving you standing a door
standing holding a door for nobody
looking like an idiot so that is when i
am dictator that is that's not going to
be allowed anymore
um if you are caught declining an act
active courtesy in that way
you will face execution
and or a 50 fine depending on how i'm
feeling
that day um because that is how i will
rule when i'm a dictator
as any good dictator would all right uh
just wanted to clarify that as we
as we wrap up hope you guys have a great
day thanks for watching thanks for
listening
godspeed